We now study a model that
involves the sum of
independent random variables,
but with a twist.
It's going to be the sum of a
random number of independent
random variables, as opposed
to a fixed number.
This is a model that shows up in
a variety of applications,
but it will also help us fine
tune our command of the law of
iterated expectations, and the
law of total variance.
The story goes as follows--
you go shopping and you visit
a number of stores, except
that the number of stores that
you will visit, is itself a
random variable.
At each one of the stores,
you spend a
certain amount of money.
We denote it by Xi.
And we make the assumption that
the Xi's are drawn from a
certain distribution.
They're identically
distributed.
And they're independent
of each other.
We also make the assumption that
the Xi's are independent
of capital N. This means that no
matter how many stores you
visit, the Xi, the amount of
money you spend in each one of
the stores that you visit, is a
random variable that's drawn
from a common distribution,
which does not change, no
matter what capital N is.
With these assumptions in place,
let us now focus on the
total amount of money that
you're spending.
This is the sum of random
variables, but with the extra
twist that the index goes up to
capital N, which is itself
a random variable.
How do we deal with
this situation?
One approach that's always worth
trying when faced with a
complicated problem is to
try to condition on some
information that will make
the problem easier.
In this case, we can condition
on the value of capital N
taking a fixed specific value
because in that case, we will
be dealing with the sum of
a finite number of random
variables where that number is
a fixed, specific number.
And this is a situation we have
encountered before and
know how to deal with it.
So let us get started.
Let us calculate the expected
value of Y, if we condition on
the number of stores.
Let's say, for example, someone
tells us that we
visited five stores.
Then, the expected value of Y
is going to be the expected
value of the sum of the amount
of money you spent in each one
of those five stores.
In our instance, it's that
random variable, capital N.
But since I told you that
capital N takes a specific
numerical value, this means that
this instance of capital
N, in the index of the
summation, can be
replaced by little n.
If I tell you that capital N
is equal to little n, then
this number here, capital N,
becomes the same as little n.
Here we use now the assumption
that capital N is independent
from the Xi's.
Here we have the sum of a fixed
number of random variables.
All of them are independent
of capital N.
If I give you some information
on capital N, this does not
change the distribution of the
Xi's, so the conditioning does
not affect the answer.
The conditional expectation is
going to be the same as the
unconditional expectation.
And now we have the expected
value of a
sum of random variables.
Each one of them has a common
expectation that's denoted
with this notation.
This is the common expected
value of all the Xi's, and
we're adding n of them, so
we obtain n times this
expectation.
Now let us apply the total
expectation theorem.
We take the familiar form of the
total expectation theorem,
and in here, ' we can plug in
the expression that we have
just found, which is n times
expected value of X. Now the
expected value of X
is just a number.
And then we have this summation
here, which we
recognize to be just the
definition of the expected
value of N.
And so we come to the conclusion
that the expected
amount of money that you will
be spending is equal to the
following product--
the expected number of stores
that you visit times the
expected amount of money
that you will be
spending in each store.
This is a quite plausible
answer.
It makes sense.
On the average, the amount of
money you spend is equal to
the average number of stores
times the average amount of
money in each store.
So it is intuitively what
you might expect.
On the other hand, we know
that reasoning "on the
average" does not always give
us the right answers.
So it's important to corroborate
this particular
formula by working out a
mathematical derivation.
Now let us carry out a second
mathematical derivation using
the law of iterated
expectations.
To use the law of iterated
expectations, we need to put
our hands on this random
variable--
the abstract conditional
expectation.
What is this object?
It's a random variable that
takes this value whenever
capital N is equal
to little n.
So it's an object that takes
this value whenever capital N
is equal to little n.
But that object is the same as
this random variable because
this is the random variable that
takes the value here when
capital N is equal
to little n.
Therefore, the abstract
conditional expectation takes
this particular form here, which
we can substitute inside
this expectation here.
And now notice that the expected
value of X is a
constant, so it can be pulled
outside this expectation.
And we're left with a product
of the expected value of N
times the expected value of
X. So this completes the
derivation of the expected value
of the sum of a random
number of random variables.